they're very different it's one of the
few mediums that you actually get a
possessory credit you know you've seen
you know Neil Simon's Plaza sweet I mean
occasionally you see Lee Daniels movie
and so forth but by and large the writer
is really the words are really so much
more of the focus and the writer is
really respected you know so much more
in theater but it's a different kind of
medium altogether you get to write in
theater you get to write stories that
are you know can be very personal and
it's very intimate and very small and
really character driven and really you
know where the where the words are just
important and it's all that dialogue and
and all of that I had a funny experience
when I when I thought summary writing
from it for many years with it for a
group called writers boot camp and and I
had a student who was a great great
woman she's an actress and she was
always kind of bucking me about you know
structure and like why do I have to
structure things this way and don't you
why do you know can't you loosen up in
terms of this and that and I would just
try to explain to her how structure and
storytelling you know worked a certain
way so she came to see the play it was
my very first play was a long time ago
and she walked out and she said to me
she hugged me and she says I I love the
play but I loved the words she's I love
that you who's you know who's teaching
me structure that you wrote these
amazing words that were just words it
was all words and character and as an
actress that's you know that was her
priority you know great words and great
character and it was really like very
eye-opening to me that like you know how
how really how different words are when
it comes to to theater because you know
movies are about showing not telling
very very often because you have the
ability to show a lot of things without
having to explain a lot of things
whereas in theater you have it's just
much much more limited in terms of what
you can show so you end up telling more
and that can be very interesting you
know and writers enjoy telling stories
which you can do on stage so I like that
the live the live part of it I write a
lot of comedies and and to to be with an
audience and and to be in an audience a
live audience that where they're
laughing and really responding and
crying or whatever and to be around them
live even different than being in the
theater watching you know watching
people watch your movie it's it's
different there's something about the
live experience that's really you know
very it's just very moving and you know
very compelling so you know that part is
great and I don't know I think as a
writer you know I I always encourage
people write screenwriters to write
plays as well I did it as a kind of way
to I wrote my first play at a time where
I just had a little time and I needed to
get something done that was mine you
know that like I didn't have to worry
about selling I didn't have to worry
about it you know fitting any particular
paradigms I could tell the story that I
wanted to tell and and it just happened
to have worked at play play was a guy I
was very proud of the play we actually
did a staged reading of it and I was
just surprised that the response to it
and then you know I was just encouraged
to you know get the play produced than
we did and it was a really fantastic
experience you also as the writer get to
deal very directly with the actors and
the director in it in a very different
way than you do in TV and film and
because because it's really more of that
team effort at that particular moment
particularly if it's a new play that
you're kind of still discovering the
words and working on the words as you're
in rehearsals and I'm also very I've
always been whether it's you know in the
film I've written or or a play and I'm
very interested in hearing what the
actors have to say because just because
you write a piece of dialogue a certain
way doesn't mean that that's somebody
who's has to say it can say it that way
or can say it can say it in a
comfortable way and I would my in my
head I hear it a certain way and what
comes out of somebody's mouth it may be
different it's always fascinating to see
which lines really don't play and really
are
- tongue twister Eeyore really really
don't make as much sense as they do and
you have that option when you're in
rehearsal live at that moment and it's
an evolutionary process we have a stage
play that you're producing coming up
yeah I have a play that I'm not
producing it's a theatre called Theatre
40 in Beverly Hills it's produced
they're producing it if they have a
they've been there a long time it's a
really really good 99-seat theater and
they have a subscription and they do a
season and this is the fifth out of the
sixth six plays of their 22 1617 season
it's called April May and June
and it's going on that it's gonna run
from March 16th through the middle of
April April 16 okay and and it's a story
of three adults sisters who named April
May and June they're in their 40s
they're a year apart and they convened
at their late mother's house which is
the house they grew up in to go through
the very end the very last of her things
and in doing so they discover something
about the mother that they just blows
their mind and it's in a small way it's
a surprise but there's a small way
connected to them in their own past and
and it's kind of how they end up coming
to terms with their image of the mother
and the whole idea we never quite know
people as much as we think particularly
parents and the sisters were three very
different but very connected close women
are they there their relationship is
really improved by this afternoon they
spend in their childhood house and it's
just how they come to terms with each
other and and the image of the mother
and they can finally you know close up
the house and move on so when you sat
down to write that were you in the same
mindset of I just want to do something
that's my own or was there some other
well what happened was I I in this
particular case I and this happens every
so often with a film script particularly
I'll come up with a title and I just
happened to the the title April May and
June just came into my head for some
reason I go that's a good title I should
do something with that and I don't know
it's just I just started writing it it
ended up becoming a you know a play a
stage play I wasn't exactly sure where
it was going when I started at a certain
point I realized there was going to be
this revelation about the mother I
realized what the revelation I wanted it
to be and it kind of evolved them from
there you know and and so it was kind of
it was kind of a unique process that way
as opposed to like having it completely
structured and having a full outline and
really knowing where I was going and
then you know I wrote it and then edited
it and ultimately got it to the place
where I felt comfortable sending it out
of showing it but it was it was it was a
very different process than then this is
the screenwriting that I do so is that
common that you will just come up with a
title and then work back once in a while
I do that once in a while you know what
happens you know especially if I were
this this this play is a
drama this and you know I hope good
laughs in it but there's also you know a
lot of tears in it as well so but on a
lot of just straight comedies that I do
you know just higher concept comedies
I've come up with titles and and then
figured out the story to go with it now
if this if there was no story attached I
wouldn't continue writing it and then
there are movies that I've written that
I've ended up changing the title many
times over things so it just you know it
depends but once in a while it's a you
know you think about how do you people
say how do you get the idea to write
this so weird we're to come up with who
thought of something like that well you
know we're writers and we write and
we're storytellers and we're creators
but sometimes they come from strange
places it can be from something that
you've observed it can be from people
that you know it can be from just coming
up with a phrase or or or in this case a
title so it's just one of those weird
you know weird things
you